allez on va passer aux débrief et pour
commencer ce débris on va bien sûr
revoir la vidéo du clash d'hier gilbert
collard face à daniel cohn bendit sens
ils ont complètement craqué alors vous
allez voir c'est la dark a dit hier et
franchement ils sont partis en cacahuète
les deux produits croyez pas regardez
l'état le non mais regardez bon l'été
sont folles 1 on va aller donc pour
commencer le débrief donc on va revoir
ce clash qui est rentré dans l'histoire
c'est ça c'est une image qui va faire le
tout on en est semaines et des semaines
et des années et des années mais vous ne
regardez pas rendu il ya deux
représentants de la république en marche
je crois que daniel aura l'honnêteté de
rock band était notre grand témoin en
foutez moi parce qu'il est quand même un
soutien à max mais on utilise maintenant
que je trouve un bon régime alors fait
mal et je suis demandé mais c'est mieux
voilà messieurs vont utiliser au moins
là pour livrer à venir
les faux culs de la politique ceux qui
ont dit chocolat
lesieu collard des bâtiments on a dit
c'est un supporter le métal c'est
insupportable
monsieur collard profiter monsieur
collard monsieur collard l'eau c'est
monsieur aulas de n'être pas autoriser
un soul avec quiconque sur son plateau
pour ceux vendus au maquereau monsieur
n'à rien
gilbert collard ceci n'est pas au
théâtre merci de votre visite à très
bientôt monsieur colas sa coquille ils
se sont foutus sur la gueule
donc ils étaient énormes blocs de
collard derrière il en a remis une
couche sur twitter daniel cohn bendit
est un représentant de la république en
marche et ne supporte pas qu'on le lui
dise dehors
voilà alors ce qui a énormément fait
réagir aussi c'est la tête d'un
spectateur il était remonté toute la
journée we qui était hyper sauté lors de
ce clash
le mec on avait la pression sur la tête
de ma mère c'est comme quand tu es
parole ils sont en vente à son donné mon
frère quand tu es chez eux nous dresse
tu vas manger ses voeux et des paroles
comme mata sont brouillés et taha n'a
pas quoi toi t'es tu ne peux pas toi qui
as pas l'habitude de lui alors lui lui
c'était et non lui c'est le meilleur
alors ça beaucoup s'inspirer beaucoup de
monde à ses regards alors bien sûr il
est plein de trucs dessus
il a dix connards il n'a pas mis un euro
dans le bocal à regarder voilà là mais
voilà sa part voilà ce qu'on a vu toute
la journée
franchement sur twitter le mec d'art il
était en top tweets
regardez tous nous regarder alors après
il y en a d'autres à regarder voilà
c'était vraiment c'était la star du web
aujourd'hui le mec voilà aujourd'hui
tout le monde a parlé de ce gala alors
les chéris nous ça nous a donné aussi
une petite idée puisqu'on sait dire en
voyant ce clash hier on s'est dit ce que
ça aurait été s'il y avait eu frappé de
yaël du dîner presque parfait le mec qui
était dans le dîner presque parfait que
oui c'est dit s'il avait été sur le
plateau
mais est-ce que ça aurait donné regarder
manque pas de respect je ne sais pas qui
sont ces gueux nina hagen il ya des faux
culs de la politique
en suivant à l'est les bulls vous il ya
même pas moyen de soyez un peu chic aux
allées dégagé dimanche à ce joli cadeau
merci de votre visite à très bientôt le
chocolat allez jozef balej qu'aux
questions
[Applaudissements]
alors se classe tout le monde a parlé
c'est vrai que bon après on va pas se
mentir
comment comment vous les avez trouvés
mine de rien les deux kiki mener le
débat alors j'ai rien contre eux mais
ils étaient complètement à la ramasse un
jeune homme est d'accord oui mais bon
quand même nom mais bon moi j'ai chéri
que je ne sais que quand il ya tous les
parents même temps la fight j'ai fait
dans le btp mais c'est vrai que
franchement pas mal c'était une
catastrophe christine nommé va là je
n'ai pas du tout être prendre la place
de jean michel maire mais je veux dire
dans btp vous avez l'habitude de gérer
ça en revanche eux ils n'ont pas
l'habitude ils ont l'habitude de
présenter un jt de 20 heures à 20 heures
et cinq sets à débat c'est à la fois un
continue donc c'est très difficile pour
eux ils n'ont pas pu maîtriser parce que
ces extrêmes ils sont très gentils mais
ils m'ont fait de la peine mort de
l'autre la peau vallée gentiment on
dirait une stagiaire mon frère soit
selon l'oms kindy mais chante l'hymne au
vert il a vécu dans les reer vous fait
réaliser le casse est pas là nettement
mieux faire j'étais tranquille jeter
correspondants mais surtout à thomas
vice et cadillac
non mais sérieusement oui alors deux
choses que je serais en colère encore là
après luis gil mais je suis debout los
alamos
il faut tenir son plateau tenir son
plâtre il arrête de dire je suis désolé
sur mon plateau si vous vous insultez
d'abord quelle image ou non de la
politique et ses métiers
je vais se lever et sans fenêtre larsson
est pas dire s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît par jour a dû se lever
j'aurais dû lever hilarante anne claire
coudray pardon hier j'ai regardé les
élections on était avec jean-michel et
oser c'est quand même fascinant ya un
journaliste qui prennent parfois la
place des autres premières questions
qu'elle pose aux responsables fin au
front national qui a gagné hier
elle voudrait rassemblement est vous
êtes vous satisfaite de ces résultats
comment perdre trois secondes sur une
scène torride iott c'est vrai avec pas
non mais c'est vrai que lui manquer de
charisme on est sur la première chaîne
orange est comme moi je suis pape
non c'est un moment je suis assez
d'accord avec chasse est d'accord avec
vous mathieu st cyr table c'est la
première chaîne européenne
merci d'en haut niveau alors
hyaluronique ou détournement vous savez
oui et non il pouvait rien faire c'était
deux fleuves ans on peut toujours faire
quelque chose et tu te lèves et tu te
tiens tu au fait qu'on réalise à bercy
j'ai ma mère c'est une enfant alors je
vous le dis allez castadi se serait levé
ils ont coupé le micro on aurait pu
alors ils ont pas tous se battre non
plus donc si ce même traitement qu'elle
est première chaîne d'europe on attend
connard va te faire [ __ ] salahuddin
ton plateau
c'est vrai mais encore sur ses huit ça
arrivait ici alors les chéris depuis
deux semaines on s'amuse avec une
application qui transforme les visages
et bayer pendant le débat en fait je me
faisais un peu sèche giuly et je me suis
amusé à filmer en fait le débat avec mon
association avec le téléphone en
utilisant l'application
alors regardez je les fais hier
franchement j'avais rien à [ __ ] après
j'ai vu bienvenue chez les ch'ti je me
suis dit que ça allait bien vieilli
regarde
alors que nous accueillons sur ce
plateau adrien 4 menace pour la france
insoumise et de votre côté
à tous égards de l'autre côté louis
aliot bonsoir pour le rassemblement
national deux autres invités jean michel
blanquer rebond soir bonsoir
un mini zoo l'éducation nationale nadine
morano bonsoir en sort bonsoir les
républicains vont aussi être concernés
gilbert collard vous allez être élu
puisque vous étiez élu en france au
palais bourbon et d'être élu eurodéputé
les fonds qu de la politique
j'attends laissez vous guider monsieur
collard monsieur connard vous êtes vous
dit rien monsieur collard l'insulté si
vous retient l'image
si vous vous quelle insulte et non
encore voyez ça ne nous fait pas s'il
collard
vous avez été devancé est ce que ça vous
attriste est ce que ça vous surprend ce
moment la retraite à 70 ans j'ai 74 ans
donc c'est fini pour moi
on a bien fait fi d'une parodie c'est
vrai c'est ce qui a fait le plus parler
hier et c'est vrai que c'était c'était
incroyable de bourse alors moi je vais
tomber avec gilbert kolly à l'époque je
vous le dis c'était en 2017
je m'en rappelle très bien puisque
l'histoire avait démarré parce qu'il
m'avait insulté sur lci regardez qu'est
ce qu'on fait on en attend c'est le
petit candidat il a rien à perdre il
balance une phrase qu'il a mis six mois
à préparer dans un atelier d'écriture et
il s'imagine pas ce que les journalistes
sont complètement à nous n'est que ça va
devenir est dans sa phrase du siècle
pour qui tous les journalistes
deviennent des hanouna bon c'est la fin
du journalisme couarde vous pensez
toujours que vous êtes sur écoute on
vous a expliqué comment fonctionner siri
à vous écouter je m'excuse je sais que
j'ai envie d'être courtois avec vous
mais ça doit plaisir ne soyez pas aussi
aussi aussi abrutis kanoun à trois fois
que vous parlez de lui non plus
tellement il était tellement abruti il
m'a dit qu'il m'avait traité d'abruti et
c'est ouf parce que quelques semaines
plus tard en fait je le redis je croise
par hasard en bas de ses vignes à ces
news et et on peut s'il y avait eu un
truc c'est que il croyait que
l'application de syrie en fait il a
parlé un jour et on l'a dit qu'est ce
que vous demander monsieur il croyait
qu'il était sur écoute se remarque
non mais ce rigolo ouais j'ai serré
compte donc je les ai rencontrés juste
après qu'ils croyaient qu'ils étaient
sur écoute 0 d'ailleurs je vais
t'envoyer schéma coloriste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
épisode hulot fait cyril hanouna se
relaient je crois que vous êtes suis
faite grâce à lui when stars telles que
les méchants gilbert rapporte naissent
au barça avec ça dit elle alors il avait
pas qu'il fait là bas donc a ouais c'est
pas sonder la crise toujours pas
aujourd'hui c'est quand ils vous voyez
vous dit susan beau c'est clair elle m'a
déjà un petit coup de poing quand même
ouais j'ai appelé on l'avait appelé à
deux ans et moi ce que je propose c'est
qu'on l'appelle à où on l'appelle en
direct ont maintenu leur ont dit des
gilbert joly numéro avant de reconnaître
non non j'ai géré j'ai eu son nouveau
numéro et mais vous vous avez changé
ah oui pas mal de vivre normalement ils
doivent savoir qu'on l'appelle alors ils
ne purent je vais l'appeler tout de
suite
gilbert collard lui dire quoi garder la
terre à terre inquiétez pas on va
l'appeler on va dire pourquoi il sait
vénère comme ça et on va voir si on
trouve aussi toujours aussi abrutis pas
à pas les mêmes insultes en direct non
là ici m'insulte là sur la tête de ma
mère un joujou turenne vénère avec lui
et moi je suis pas et daniel cohn bendit
ans alors attendez bail pour l'instant
il répond pas je rappelle qu'il est
21h11 on essaie d'appeler gilbert
collard
cet automne est bon jour tant qu'unique
avec le téléphone portable de gilbert
collard
[Rires]
on dirait qu'il a fait lui même
l'aventuré frère j'aurais voulait pas
parler honda elle s'inquiétait pas il
améliorera le rappeler on va le rappeler
on va le rapper avec ça nous a aussi
inspiré
je vous le dis on s'est dit c'est le
grand frère avait été là hier soir
pascal le grand frère
oui elle est horrible on l'avait agoni
lien n'est faux cul de la politique
c'est pitoyable
pitoyable j'ai les oreilles qui vont
saigner l'a tellement tellement les
insultes sont énormes il est violent
verbalement moi c'est juste
insupportable faisons pas que ce serait
si vous n'êtes pas autorisé un soul avec
quiconque sur un plateau lui dès que je
vais débarquer je m'occupais de son
coeur chadha photo s'est régalé avec ça